here's what would happen if a Megalodon  shark fought the Kraken the Megalodon  would have the initial Advantage sensing  the vibrations of the giant Beast ahead  stealthily it would stalk the Kraken  suddenly the Megalodon would Swim full  speed at the Kraken ramming into it and  sinking its teeth into the kraken's  delicate skin the Kraken weighing around  three tons would be no match for the 50  tons of shark that just collided with it  at high speed the Megalodon would  release the Kraken and circle again  preparing for its next strike but at  this point the Kraken would vomit its  digested food all the different smells  and vibrations would disorient the  Megalodon the Kraken would then whip its  tentacles around grabbing hold of the  Megalodon with its Wicked hooks the  Kraken would then bring the shark to its  mouth and with its giant beak it would  bite into the monster shark one or maybe  two bites and the Megalodon would be  defeated so